[Music]
sir we're gonna take these funds for the
Old Town Road we're gonna buy a ton of
black ass for gonna take these funds for
the Old Town Road we gonna yeah hey and
then also fix potholes we could take
these funds for the Old Town Road and
maybe build a brand new stadium tire job
to fix the Old Town Road we mustn sure
that is he even listening I'm thinking
no this is so exciting look the roof is
shining so touched by this project I
named it Joe Biden sir this is dismaying
taxpayers are pay
studies show these never create economic
growth you're saying can't nobody tell
me nothing
you can't tell them nothing can't nobody
tell me nothing
you can't live nothing the roads are all
unstable should fix them before rape how
broken are we talking think month old
iPhone K we should not be subsidizing a
billion-dollar guy that will
subsequently leverage move our mascot
has a try can't nobody tell me nothing
you can't tell if nothing can't nobody
tell me nothing
you can't tell them nothing or the
neighborhood's complain and eminent
domain it toll road gas tax let's call
it a day
it's not a scandal but it tell me
nothing
you can't tell em nothing can't nobody
tell me nothing you can't tell em
[Music]
[Music]